okay I wasn't planning to extreme today
but here I am this is gonna be a very
quick one I'm gonna play one game time
for like a ten plus five game playing
currents 21 play E for my face is really
bright I like as my windows open hmm
change the exposure explain I have three
like some normal opening let's play
Spanish I posted the video on YouTube
yesterday from a stream of a few days
ago I played the exchange Roy worked out
nicely I can't play the exchange Roy in
this position as d6 is a tricky move
let's just castle at some point I might
want to play d4 like d4 here maybe D for
D for looks nice hmm makes sense when
the Knights pinned and the knight
doesn't have influence on either of
these squares and I'm assuming that he
can't get away with taking the pond also
thanks to the new subs give you a shout
out in just one moment if I take yeah
that's fine he's probably gonna play
Bishop d7
not sure who the first one was oh is P P
D bull [ __ ] yeah thanks for the sub and
thinks Samsonite for the Sun appreciate
it Bishop d7 when tempted here it's a
plain night at 5:00 it feels weird but
it also feels right I mean then he is g6
though the a g6 could be annoying the
night h6 what's going on there
the idea would be to play like to go
after f7 I don't know if that works oh
wait night at 5 3 takes I'm happy so g6
my nature 6 Bishop g7 Bishop c4 castles
Bishop g5 and he has like 95 ok let's
just play normal I'm going to develop
it's fun to get carried away with these
sort of lines but sometimes you just
have to follow opening principles
developed to control the center before
going crazy like here maybe now I go
crazy it was 9.5 let's do it imbalance
things a little bit expecting that he'll
take whatever happens whites gonna get
the bishop hair and that will be my main
asset for for the middle game
and hello to people in the chats delayed
hello - psycho Brooks Belgian Alice
Didier Drogba cool guy you need the N
what's the theme of the stream the theme
is just one game that's all I have time
for I have a busy schedule today
so not too much time for streaming okay
so I could take the bishop I could just
leave my knight here
I mean Queen f3 is a move I want to play
but then 95 play rookie one let's play
rookie one normal move leaving the
tension trying to make him think he
takes and I take back have you guys work
e8 preparing Bishop f8 then I probably
capture the bishop because I want the
bishop hair and I just want to get the
position where I have the bishop hair
and I have a little bit more space with
my pawn on e4
or maybe my pawn will be on f5 and then
I'll have to guess if he takes and I
take back and he plays Queen d7 I have
to start defending it maybe then I
played Bishop g5 he takes it could get
weird
titled arena and I'm not gonna play the
whole thing and I don't know if I'm
gonna stream it because I'm working I'm
working in a school today like starting
it too but I might play if I have time
we'll see I mean I want to play like the
first maybe half hour try and play
Carlson again but yeah this time around
I can't I can't play and scream the
whole thing so he's thinking
I mean I'm expecting one of these two
moves sg6 the g6 looks weakening
actually g6 is just a terrible move
because when I take and then all his
dark squares are weak I also have the
darks for Bishop
the best way to answer the ISIS question
the best way to contact me is through my
website
I am rosen.com slash contact there's a
forum there I have a backlog of emails
so at this point it's taking like three
to seven days to respond to things like
a few days every week I'll just try and
sit down and just respond to as many
emails as possible but then they keep
piling on it's it's difficult but send
me an email that's the easiest way
through the website I'm not accepting
challenges Magisto so no there's no
reason to challenge me in the future I
accept most anytime control
recently I've been enjoying the slower
games a bit more chill okay let's take
there's a game that I've studied which
had kind of this early pawn coming to f5
as a game between a hammer and xud and
hammer just won in like 20 something
moves ok so he plays him of 97 or 97
probably preparing this and this and the
first thing that comes to mind is like
tactics involving like taking one of
these things but nothing seems to work
so 95 looks attractive
imagining like just improving the pieces
like 95 put the Queen on h5 I'm trying
to think I had here like 95 Bishop f6
then I could get both bishops activates
a queen I'm gonna start with 95 because
there's many situations where I'll be
happy to play Knight takes Bishop hey
another sub sphere arrow thanks for
something but I don't want to take the
bishop immediately because I still have
the space advantage so maybe I'll play
like queen h5 you could play g6
Queen h3
looks Pleasant and I would like to play
a move that has a more direct threats
but I don't see anything to immediate so
let's play this may be it well all do or
at least I'll consider is Bishop d2 then
eventually taking and putting the bishop
on c3 looks reasonable I'd probably have
to calculate Bishop takes me to the rook
b1
there's also ideas of like lifting the
rook over rookie 3 work h3 sometimes
physicians like this is just good to
identify all of the resources so I'm not
entirely sure what to expect next but I
just want to familiarize myself with the
potential attacking ideas I'm gonna make
the notification things smaller it's a
little too big there thanks for the
follow by the way so I'm looking for
other resources another resource which
hammer actually played in the game that
I was thinking of is this like g4 g5 it
looks exotic the Kingston on g1 but it's
very possible because the bishop could
get kicked around
I'm realizing if he plays g6 again I'm
very happy to take and the darks race
will be week I guess g6 takes Queen
takes Queen h3
he could take on that five we trade and
it's a nice and game you're a freshman
in chess what does that mean freshmen in
chess IT Swasey baby
Oh does that mean just beginner thinking
freshman like that you're in high school
or college the best way to get started
go to Lee chess org slash learn and it's
like that I think the title of the page
is literally like chess basics
let me type that in the chat a chest on
the work slash learn there you go
and like it's it's so easy just to go
through it starts out really easy and
then then you'll at least learn the
basics yeah I don't think there there's
a major that exists yet you can like
major in chess there is a minor in chess
so she uh the school I graduated from
Webster University the the semester
after I graduated they they unveiled the
chess minor and they're offering like
academic courses in chess okay Bishop e5
f4 looks tempting but then there's
Bishop d4 check
already envisioning like some crazy
meeting ideas there's a it's a very
specific Nate that I'm I would really
like to accomplish in this position but
might be overly risky
okay I'm gonna start with Bishop here
the idea is I want to provoke f6 because
if he plays off six I mean it looks
solid for black but now the knight can't
come there and e6 is really weak I could
even consider a Bishop c4 here but I
think I'll start with I play Bishop c4
let's start with Bishop d2
and the the long-term problem for black
is this e six square it's a light square
and I have a light squared Bishop and I
have many ways to attack it with all of
my pieces and if like if a knight ever
lands on e6 then it's gonna be heaven
but I'm also interested in just like
destroying the King because there's
gonna be some mating ideas now he's
probably thinking about taking the pawn
which would be interesting actually
thinking of some crazy line like if he
takes the pawn I take the Knights I
throw in the Czech King h8 and then
rookie 3 and then if he takes on 81 I
play Queen takes h7 King takes h7 and
rook h3 checkmates that would be an ice
queen sack
that's the mate I was actually thinking
of around the point he played Bishop e5
e6 is trying to disturb my my deep plan
so I think here I'll play Bishop c4 it's
taking no longer makes any sense cuz I
want to keep the light squared Bishop
and there's actually still ideas like
this this could be really nice if you
place King h8 I'm gonna play rook e3 and
then the threat is Queen takes h7 King
takes h7 rook h3 King g8 and Knight
takes f6 or 97 both with double
checkmate
I don't think I can take immediately but
if I take and then rookie 3 he has
something like g5 so rookie 3 pieces are
coming to life he's low on time I don't
know what Black's gonna do here I mean
he might he might be thinking that my
threats rook age three and then age six
but then Bishop takes hsx okay so that's
another another scary threat but of
course this is the main threats
I don't think that defense I think it's
time to sack a queen after rook h3
there's only one legal move and now
let's take on f6 that was nice
that's a miniature 19 moves yeah I was
feeling really good like when he played
f6 just I guess it starts with Bishop g5
like recognizing it's a move I want to
provoke could go to analysis board hello
- toilet noggin know if he's still here
oh he is maybe here toilet noggin I was
trying to play an exchange Roy but he
didn't play a 6
he played d6 decided to play had to play
normal chess so I wanted to find you see
hammer xud for anyone who plays efore
this hammer dude game is a classic so it
involved like some some coordinate kind
of like Philidor opening
let me open a new tab or we can go to
and just go to study
and I'm just making a study with these
two games because I feel like they were
overlapping themes recapping this game
real quick I was honestly out of any
sort of preparation when I played d4 but
I knew I knew basic ideas I assume that
efore could really never be taken I
think after rook e3 it's pretty much
lost I was thinking he should probably
play aged six but then I'm still gonna
lift the rook over probably to h3 and
then this is just a monster threat I
don't think black can stop it so did the
framing went off there we go yeah
nothing much more to talk about let me
show the the hammer zoot game just for
people who play this opening for whites
it was similar and then the key moment
is coming up here Knight f5 just getting
the bishop pair black decided to take
and I really like this game because when
I first saw it I was very suspicious
about this pawn but hammer just
justified it by playing g4 and then like
the Kings side was really safe this is a
really nice kind of setup with ideas of
f4 later
and he was very patient too like b3 is a
nice move not the first move that maybe
comes to mind but he wants to play f4
and he doesn't want to allow Knight c4
so when b3 is played f4 is actually
threatening to trap the night before and
before such restrictive chests and like
once the Knights are bad then he just
destroys black on the Kings side
yeah f6 is nice opening this diagonal
and then this is basically unstoppable
too much pressure now the mating idea on
g7 is it's hard to stop
well black resigns here maybe black
could play 96 no but then Bishop takes
off five yeah there's problems on both
of these squares anyway people are free
to use a study to analyze on their own
I'll rename this playing against
Philidor type stuff if spell fill is it
one oh I think it's one l huh it might
be too else I forget anyway I don't have
much time to play anymore so I'm gonna
end it there thanks guys for watching
I'm gonna try and stream more when I get
the chance this was also a test of my
Internet's cuz I call it Comcast
yesterday I didn't call Comcast I
chatted with Comcast and they like reset
the modem so it's good to see that there
were no like drops in connection like
the the little green box was was green
the whole time
just great
okay I'm taking off I will see you guys
in the future